hallo mein name ist luca unter spiels
länder kam vor drei jahren raus und ich
habe es jetzt auch mal für mich entdeckt
ich habe einfach bock aufs bett und habe
mir gedacht ich spiele das einfach mal
allerdings damit es nicht ganz so wie
für mich wieder habe ich gedacht aber
wenn ich den sender sehe trinke ich
einen shot aus diesem wissen sound hier
klicken einfach auf star game und zwar
immer wenn ich den sender sehe muss ich
einen schock ihr ostring mir damit ihr
seht das ist noch völlig eingebrochen
ist hört man dass das riecht dazu muss
ich sagen bin ich krank
ich weiß nicht ob das gut oder schlecht
ich glaube da muss ich nicht großartig
erklären ich musste durch den wald
laufen und muss acht seiten finden und
wenn ich das geschafft habe mich quasi
gewonnen ich kann auch schneller laufen
so wenn ich so gedrückt halte ich kann
mir erst die flash lite ausmachen
und jetzt werden wir den mal gehörig in
den arschloch zu denken ich wäre glaube
ich wert verlieren ich muss tatsächlich
dazu sagen dass ich dieses spiel 2012
schon mal gespielt habe allerdings habe
ich das nicht aufgenommen weil ich habe
mich einfach mega show und dachte mir jo
luca wenn du so eine busse bis da lebte
das lokal nicht hoch fasst es da ist
sich uva der hallo
von wegen die taste gedrückt jetzt habe
ich in seinem behinderten sohn drin wie
kriegt ihn raus
entschuldigung also und co kann ich
dinge sind okay dann okay gesagt ich
dachte das wetter gesicht gewesen aber
es war nur ein warum ich tue was mir
meine bisheriges länder erfahrung gesagt
teil beziehungsweise gezeigt hat ist man
soll sich nicht umdrehen kann findet
meine taschenlampe schwacher wird okay
taschenlampe ist aus gerade ein bisschen
anfällig gesagt die sowieso
okay okay okay wir gucken da hinten war
nämlich das werde ich jetzt noch mal
kurz das verschneiden dass ich hoffe er
kann jetzt nicht wie vor mich laufen ich
fühle hier ein wenig was rein ich fange
erst mal so leicht an das hier ist
schott level glaube ich so in etwa hier
wenn ihr meinen finger seht das ist so
finger halber finger keine ahnung ich
trinke das jetzt mal wenn ich bin krank
auf das gute daran nicht schlug noch
kopf ich weiß nicht ob es daran liegt
dass ich erkältet bin aber es schmeckt
tatsächlich nach kotze im nachhinein
schmeckt sie doch eine brausetablette
aber irgendwie jetzt gerade hat es
einfach nur noch aus als ob der da immer
noch steht die rheinländer man auf dich
freunde
ich glaube das schmeckt nicht nach
kurzer sondern das ist einfach weil mir
die kurse hoch kommen sondern wissen wir
jetzt in welche richtung wir uns
definitiv nicht reden sollen ich
versuche mir noch ein bisschen schneller
zu laufen so dass wir mal irgendwie so
eine verdammte scheiße seite noch sind
welcher keinen bock dass wir hier
rausgehen aus dem spiel und nur eine
seite gefunden haben wenn euch das die
gefällt eventuell mit sender challenges
könnt ihr mir auch einfach mal einen
daumen hoch erlassen bzw
noch viel besser oder macht einfach
beides daumen hoch da lassen und in die
kommentare schreiben hat die als nächste
challenge machen soll ich weiß dieses
spiel ist und eventuell sagen ganzen
frieds unter euch auf youtube aktuell
gewesen
luca ich schicke der sache die aktuellen
ich habe spielt einfach drauf ich hatte
lust habe deswegen hab ich mir gedacht
habe
da muss doch irgendwo so eine scheiße
dran sein oder hallo free als ob hier
einfach mitten in der wiese sonnen
verdammte scheiße baum steht und da ist
einfach keine seite dran brauchen
wo denn jetzt schon wieder aber ich habe
keinen gesehen ehrlich gesagt vielleicht
scheint da hinter dem baum oder so aber
nein nein taschenlampe bei der
taschenlampe geht nur wenn man den
fendant hat denke ich auch sieht und ich
habe ihn nicht gewinnen kann den baum
[Musik]
es ist schon wieder so gut ding ich
schwitze richtig mal nicht nur scheiß
schule macht dass man eine
mittelschnelle kogler du heilige scheiße
hier ist ländern auf dich was soll das
denn ich dachte kann sich nicht bewegen
ich dachte das ist nur wenn ich den mann
der ist einfach vor mich gesprochen der
blödmann okay ich bin noch richtig
fertig vom letzten short aber das land
braucht dich
euro in monochrom wunder euro muss das
hier leider abbrechen
ihr grab meiner ganzen halt ich bin noch
mega krank von dem video date mein
ganzer halten brennt gerade einfach nur
das tut mir leid
doch wenn ich gesund bin mache ich das
noch mal wieder aber jetzt gerade hätte
ich gesagt wenn ihr wollt dass ich
eventuell noch mal so eine challenge ins
länder mache oder einem anderen spiel
oder die gleiche technische dem anderen
spiel oder eine andere challenge und
anderen spielern eine andere challenge
ins länder oder nach rechts in die
kommentare ich würde mich über eine
bewertung freuen und ich geh jetzt kurz
dem schiff